[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
britney spears conservatorship battle is
back in the courtroom
and this time a judge rules against her
father what has gone down
has been unethical and the process has
not been due for her
defense attorneys for the former
president present their case at the
trump impeachment trial
we break down their first amendment
claims it is constitutional
cancel culture did the former attorney
general interfere in a plea deal
in the george floyd case our experts
take on a report
of bill barr stopping a bargain for
ex-cop derrick chauvin
he did not want to put his thumb on a
scale of justice
plus a grand jury's decision on whether
officers should be indicted for pushing
an elderly protester to the ground
the grand jurors voted to no bill the
case
which means that they dismissed the case
all right law and crime daily covering
court cases from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
britney spears won a small victory in
court this week against her father jamie
in her conservatorship case
angina levy is here to tell us more
about it and the attention the case is
getting
yeah brian britney spears wants her
father jamie removed completely as
conservator
of her estate a judge ruled this week
that jamie
spears and a trust company will manage
britney's finances together
but the conservatorship battle continues
outside the stanley moss courthouse in
los angeles
members of the free brittany movement
chanted their support for britney spears
what do we want when do we want it
spears has asked a judge to remove her
father jamie as conservator of her
estate
the court has already named bessemer
trust as a co-conservator at spear's
request to manage her finances
why can't she choose what she's able to
do from her day to day why does she have
to get approval for who she can hang out
with
why is she not allowed to choose who she
wants in charge of her assets
bible girl is a free britney advocate
brittany has been a person who's been
with me when no one else was
she and others attended a virtual rally
during the latest hearing in spears case
speer's lawyer says she doesn't want her
father as conservator
while jamie spears lawyer says brittany
said in 2008 that she wanted him in
charge
anytime there's that amount of money to
be made you have to question the motives
of
everyone close to that person the new
york times documentary framing britney
spears has brought more attention to the
conservatorship battle
spears's first attorney said in it that
britney never wanted her father named
conservator
even back in 2008 and recordings of
spears have emerged where she claims her
father threatened to take her children
away
if she ends the conservatorship
meanwhile britney spears's fans say they
have her back
we're out here keeping the heat on the
conservatorship case we want the judge
to know that the world is watching and
we want her to make the right decision
and rule in favor of brittany i feel
like uh it's a big deal i mean this is
someone's like life i know it doesn't
affect any of us and it's not very
uh that important to all of us but this
is someone's life that is very important
and jamie spears had objected to any
attempt to limit his control
over the estate the judge ruled that
bessemer trust and jamie spears should
work together to come up with a budget
for the estate
the next hearing is next month brian
thanks for the update angeanette joining
us today is defense attorney and former
prosecutor bernardo violona
and terry austin terry with
co-conservatorships with equal power
over spears
estate do you foresee any fighting in
between these two parties that can maybe
i don't know bring more light to the
conservatorship
you know i think there might be some
fighting between the two
i know that the judge obviously decided
long ago
that they should have this
co-conservatory but
remember here that the best of her trust
is making some decisions
in favor of brittany and brittany is a
little bit concerned about what her
father's going to do and i think
he's concerned that he's losing power so
that's why he's made
these recent motions and the judge has
basically said
look you're going to have equal power
you can't make decisions by yourself
yeah that's power struggle between the
two is going to be very interesting to
watch
but not a minor victory but a victory
nonetheless
with britney spears having a
co-conservatorship of her choosing
what do you think the next step is for
the free brittany movement
well brian this case is going to be a
long battle i mean this was just a small
step in favor of britney but it's no way
to the end
what i think the free britney movement
is looking for is that
ultimately britney decides that she
wants to do another tour
or perform again because britney spears
has said that she is afraid of her
father and while her father
has control over her estate that she
will not perform again
so hopefully there is still some kind of
hope for the free brittany movement
but i think this is the case that's
going to be in the courts for many years
yeah now angenette as we saw there there
was a lot of support
outside the courthouse for free britney
i would not have bet against that
um anjanette are both what are both
sides
saying after the hearing though you know
what uh brian it's interesting too that
you mentioned the support outside the
courthouse because there was also a lot
of support at that virtual rally
at least a thousand people were in there
that was the limit and i actually tried
to get back in and was barred because it
had reached the thousand person limit so
this is a big
movement out there all of her fans
lawyers for both sides have not gotten
back to me actually i
reached out to britney spears herself
she has not responded
jamie spears his lawyer has said though
in the past
that the estate has flourished under his
watch it went from being in debt to
having 60 million dollars in the bank
so they're saying look he's been doing a
great job
you know he should stay on this so there
could still be another petition from
brittany's lawyer to remove him as
conservator as bernarda said she's not
going to tour again until her dad
is has been removed as conservator this
is just one
more chapter in the long book that is
this conservatorship battle thank you
all for your contribution
still ahead on law and crime daily the
supreme court halts what would have been
the first execution
of a death row inmate this year but
first does the first amendment protect
the former president
from accusations of inciting an
insurrection or legal analysis
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
attorneys for former president donald
trump are presenting their case in the
senate impeachment trial
they say the president is protected by
the first amendment
mr trump was an elected official and
there is an entire
body of law supreme court landmark cases
supporting the conclusion that mr trump
actually has enhanced free speech
rights because he is an elected official
attorneys for donald trump cited several
landmark supreme court cases
including woodview georgia which
overturned the conviction of a local
sheriff for interfering with a grand
jury's investigation
the court held that the first amendment
protected an elected public official's
speech
because the voting controversy directly
affected the sheriff's political career
in another landmark case bond v floyd
the supreme court said the state
legislature could not punish an elected
official
accused of advocating for burning draft
cards during the vietnam war
the supreme court held that the georgia
house of representatives
was in fact forbidden by the first
amendment
from punishing bond by not ceding him
for advocating against the policy of the
united states
and a third case brandenburg v ohio
which ruled in favor of ku klux klan
leader clarence brandenburg
who invited a tv station to film a rally
in which he called for
revengeance against african americans
jews and those who supported them
the film was taken on a remote private
farm
in which apparently there is no evidence
whatsoever that these people were not
invitees present on that farm
by authority of the ownership of the
farm the defense already facing pushback
from 144 leading first amendment lawyers
who signed a letter calling the
arguments quote legally frivolous
including father of law and crime
founder dan abrams floyd abrams
he was telling them to go
and he would go with them he never used
the words
you know take down the capital but but
he used a lot of incendiary language
about something which was literally
about to occur
you'll never take back our country with
weakness
you have to show strength and you have
to be strong
the reality is mr trump was not
in any way shape or form
instructing these people to fight or to
use
physical violence what he was
instructing them to do
was to challenge their opponents in
primary elections
to push for sweeping election reforms
here to break down the defense's
arguments during the impeachment trial
is defense attorney bernardo villalona
and terry austin
terry the defense argued a few scotus
cases one of which
was bond v floyd you researched the case
and thought that it wasn't quite on
point
why you know the bond case was
totally different from what's going on
now with the trump case julian bond was
a civil rights leader and
he basically said that he was against
the vietnam war and because of that
congress said no you can't be a part of
congress well the supreme court said
well yes you can
you can express your point of view
and still serve in congress so that's a
punishment that is not going to be
upheld
what trump is doing is in his rally he
specifically said
go to the capitol he specifically said
fight
and he knew for a fact that they were
going to do that
and he didn't do anything once the
violence took place so
it's totally different there was no
incitement of an insurrection in the
bond case and ironically bond was
arguing that he was a pacifist
and did not want to participate in the
war for that purpose he wasn't
encouraging people
to go out and i don't know storm the
capital bernardo the defense pointed to
political hyperbole of democrats to show
not what aboutism but that this is just
how politicians speak
what did you think of that argument well
what the defense did is that they
performed and put out a mixtape of
different statements made by democrats
and in doing that what they try to do is
what i call smoking mirrors
is to take away the focus of what these
jurors are
here to do which is to decide whether
the speech
was one of incitement we know what trump
said if you don't fight like hell
you're going to lose your country so
based on that where he's
intentionally sending them to fight he
knew
the power of his words and then taken
into context of how it took place and
when it took place
obviously he definitely incited them and
wanted violence that they placed
all right what's still going on we'll
keep an eye on the impeachment trial
thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily an ivy
league murder an
mit graduate named as a person of
interest in the death of a yale student
plus on updating the prosecution of the
officer accused of murdering george
floyd
has he accepted a plea deal the rejected
offer next
new reaction to a reported plea deal
offered in the george floyd case
and how the nation's former top
prosecutor intervened in the bargain
according to a report by the new york
times shogun had agreed to plead guilty
to third degree murder and a 10-year
prison sentence
but the report says then attorney
general william barr
rejected the deal because he was worried
it would look too lenient
the times said the deal needed federal
approval because chauvin asked to serve
his time
in federal prison a judge presiding over
the case also denied the state's request
to reinstate third degree murder charges
against all four of the former
minneapolis police officers
chauvin is now facing two charges of
second-degree manslaughter
and second-degree murder former federal
prosecutor gene rossi
says attorney general bill barr made the
right decision
chauvin attorneys went to the justice
department and said listen
if the justice department closes or does
not open a civil rights investigation
criminal which is a tough road to hoe
if you don't open that i will go into
minneapolis state court
i will eat a third degree murder charge
and serve at least
10 years okay that's what that's what
happened here
the department of justice does not
prosecute state murder charges
unless it's on federal property so
that's what happened
you stop feds from investigating me for
civil rights
and i'll go into a state court and i'll
eat third degree murder
and bill bar did the right thing because
he didn't have all the evidence
he didn't have all the facts
quick side note the state's motion to
the court of appeals to rejoin the 4x
cops case
was denied and chauvin will proceed to
court alone
on march 8th now here to discuss the
report of a plea deal
negotiations in the george floyd case is
bernardo villalona and terry austin
bernardo your former prosecutor was this
the right move by former attorney
general william barr
it was definitely the right move for a
former attorney general barr
to just stick his nose somewhere else
because for him to have taken part in an
investigation and a prosecution
that belonged to the state and not
giving them opportunity to do the
investigation
would have been too much for the people
of minnesota as well as the people from
this country
to be able to respect so for barr to
have said no for the plea deal
i think is definitely acceptable this is
again it's a state pace
what's interesting enough is that the
court has already dismissed
the third degree charge so that was the
case the charge that they were looking
for charleven to actually plead to so
that is no longer an option for chobin
i mean i would agree with you and gene
rossi but terry playing devil's advocate
wouldn't it be uh quick and easy just to
take this plea deal much like they see
in
sexual assault cases to resolve it
without having to re-traumatize
witnesses at trial
could that have been a reason to take
the plea yeah you know honestly brian
there are always two sides to every
issue i mean on the one hand
a swift and fair resolution and i
emphasize
fair could have spared the public this
tragedy to go through this again
but you have to make sure that the
punishment meets the gravity of the
crime and i think
here there might be many people who
believe that 10 years is not nearly
enough
i can definitely see that after that
video we saw of george floyd
dying a lot of people would have been
very angry at 10 years especially when
you compare it to other charges thank
you both
when we come back video shows two
buffalo police officers pushing an
elderly protester to the ground
while they won't be facing charges still
ahead
now to new haven connecticut where
authorities say an mit graduate
is a person of interest in the murder of
a yale grad student
authorities are on the hunt for kingsian
pond in connection with the murder of
kevin jiang
police say pond was in possession of a
stolen vehicle in the area
at the time jiang was shot and killed
the north haven police department say
they came into contact with pawn
soon after the killing witnesses to the
murder report seeing
a shiny new black vehicle flee the scene
new haven police chief ottoniel reyes
says they're on the lookout into the
possibility of a romantic connection
linking the suspect to the victim
the new haiti police department's
homicide unit is looking
for mr king swan khan date of birth of 4
16 1991.
we know that mr pong is a graduate of
mit
and has an affiliation with that
university
am asking that the public knows that mr
pong should be considered armed and
dangerous
and that he that extreme caution should
be used
if if you come in contact with this
individual we are exploring
every angle um related to this
investigation
and related to every person involved the
victim
his fiancee his extended family
and to include the suspect or the person
of interest that we've identified here
before you
and so at this point we're not prepared
to tell you what our
information is regarding their
involvement and whether or not there is
a connection between that
and this investigation what we can tell
you is that we are exploring that
the u.s supreme court blocked the
execution of alabama death row inmate
willie b smith iii
scheduled for thursday night the justice
has upheld a lower court stay
on the grounds that his personal pastor
must be allowed in the chamber
with him when he receives the lethal
injection smith was convicted in the
1991
abduction robbery and murder of 22 year
old shama
ruth johnson a spokesperson for the
alabama department of corrections said
the execution would not proceed because
non-prison staff are not allowed in the
room
for security reasons criminal charges
against two buffalo police officers have
been dismissed
officers aaron tolgowski and robert
mccabe were charged with felony assault
after videos show the officers pushing
an elderly protester to the ground
last summer 75 year old martin gugino
was among 20 demonstrators protesting
the death
of george floyd after curfew the fall
left gugino with a brain injury
and a fractured skull grand jury voted
no true bill
leading to the dismissal of the charges
in a press conference announcing the
grand jury's decision
district attorney john flynn adamantly
stood by his decision to charge the
officers
i do not manipulate charges uh at the
time
uh and you know still to this day i'll
stand by the fact that charges should
have been filed
and there was probable cause at that
time
to charge that offense and i stand by
that
i make no apologies for it uh and if i
had to go back over again i'd do the
same thing
without any question about it okay to
each one of you and i right now
and i am telling you that i sandbagged
nothing i went into that grand jury
i put all relevant evidence
into that grand jury i put multiple
witnesses in that grand jury
okay i put everything that was
not cumulative into that grand jury
and you got that word on that i
again that's all i can say
here for legal analysis on the lack of
an indictment in buffalo is bernardo
villalona and terry austin
bernarda this doesn't make sense to me
from someone i mean both of us practice
here in the state
you got to prove two things you got to
prove he's over the age of 65
and that he was injured i'm not asking
for these officers to get locked up but
no indictment this makes no sense
what do you think exactly especially
when you're talking about a grand jury
presentation because the grand jury
presentation is a different burden of
proof
you don't have to prove the defendant's
guilt beyond a reasonable doubt
so i don't know why is it that a grand
jury at least 12 of those grand jurors
decided to issue a render a no true bill
because we already know
look the victim is over 65 years old
both police officers are at least
10 years younger and the intent of those
officers when they place
their hands on the body of this victim
and
pushed him down speaks for itself as to
the intent to cause physical injury
so unfortunately because there's a no
true bill the minutes are sealed so we
will never know
what was presented to that grand jury
it's just peculiar it doesn't make sense
based on i think what we both know and
understand in the state of new york
terry what was your reaction to no true
indictment and do you think there's a
possible civil claim here for the victim
well you know i agree with you both i
think this shocks the conscience there's
no question that a 75 year old man
wasn't a threat to anyone and you could
see that in the video
you know as for a civil case anything is
possible and i haven't seen anything yet
but they could file a claim for
negligence here because
the police officers owed a duty to this
individual
and they failed that duty and he was
definitely harmed
yeah not just a heart but not helping
afterwards i mean bernardo terry thank
you very much
and thank you for joining us here at
long crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you